dunder-mifflin this is Aaron he's not
available right now
uh-huh yes sure I'll give him a message
when he gets up gets back
Michael had chicken pot pie for lunch
actually let me rephrase that Michael
had an entire chicken pot pie for lunch
it let me be more specific Michael ate
an entire family sized
chicken pot pie for lunch and then he
promptly fell asleep so we're all trying
to be very quiet so as to not wake them
up before 5:00 p.m. which actually
should be in about 10 minutes what do
you need from me normally I don't
condone leaving early but I have an
appointment with the horse doctor how
that horse became a doctor I don't know
no I'm kidding
he's just a regular doctor who shoots
your horse in the head when its leg is
broken
like clockwork oh wow okay all right
let's all go home come on see you all
Damali my god Oh
alrighty let's get started what is she
into I know Pam pretty well I know the
things that she likes and just as
important I know the things that she
hates so one of the things that she
likes is pranks and the things that she
hates frisbee based competitions are you
kidding she I started the main frisbee
golf club at Cornell where I went to
college I live to frolf lead off with
that she loves hunting she also loves
those ads for Six Flags with the old guy
then I got dad and also do you speak Pig
Latin
hello this is Dwight Schrute hello hello
this is Dwight hello hello yes we do
have that hold on one second Jim what
are you doing
and how many would you like hang that up
right absolutely I can get that up to
you immediately
this man is an impostor do not do
business with him this is not right rude
Dwight left his cellphone on his desk so
naturally I paired it to my headset okay
fine
I'll just let it go to voicemail hello
is Dwight hey is this right yes it is oh
my goodness you sound sexy oh thank you
I'm working out whoa
Pam you are not talking to Dwight right
now you're talking to Jim Dwight no Pam
I'm over here I'm confused
disconnect that right now you give me
your earpiece can't do that unsanitary
ah
okay you know what fine I will reprogram
my phone to go to my office phone done
was the white oh and I forged his desk
phone to mine oh hello mutter good news
I've married tell thaw sir
such a nice woman hope this helps
what are you doing Shh
don't be scared
it works
I'm a llama thing listen you're cute
there's no getting around it
so I don't know if you like country
music but I was thinking maybe one of
these days we can drive out to a field
crank up some tunes smoke a few back in
new toes maybe even toss a disc around
but wait who do you pay em pay
Wow
Wow that was WOW Lipan night oh you know
what
sorry I forgot to tell you i intercepted
a transmission earlier and it seems that
the CIA is gonna need to why you down in
their headquarters at Langley for
training and an ice cream social with
the other agents we should get him a bus
ticket to make its trip easy
I don't know that would make our $75
well maybe the CIA could send a
helicopter
you have been compromised abort mission
destroy phone
Michael since it is your 15th
anniversary at the company I thought it
might be appropriate to begin the
festivities with a 15 minute
round of applause I like it followed by
a 15 minute moment of silence I don't
know is it classy enough Jim enough with
the classy okay I just feel like after
15 years of this company Bravo by the
way that we should celebrate with a very
classy event a night to remember I think
you're right
this party has to have all the
excitement drama and intrigue of my time
here and of course classic and classy
yeah Michael you're just agreeing with
him cuz he's wearing a tux don't you see
what he's doing here last week Dwight
sent out a memo about the dress code so
this is me showing him that I'm taking
it very seriously oh here's one a string
quartet playing classical music hmm you
know that's good but it's not classy I
I need something classy like the opening
of a car dealership that's it or mr.
peanut
yes mr. peanut is not classic yes he is
a regular peanut he just happens to have
a cane a monocle and a top hat that's
what makes him classy okay how about
this an ice sculpture shaped like you
covered in chocolate-covered
strawberries Oh Dwight you're trying too
hard and that's just not classy you see
the thing about classy is it's a state
of mind well I'm sorry I just don't know
what classy is then okay let's just try
this one on for size and I apologize cuz
it's right off the top of my head an ice
sculpture of you completely surrounded
by a variety chuckling covered fruits
strawberries that's inspired I said that
not classy not classy at all big glass a
French classic you ready hmm
you kidding I was born ready I don't
know how to tell you this but we have a
little bit of a problem no what the
minister just told me
that it's tradition for the bestisch
mensch to be older than the groom oh
come on I've never heard of since you
haven't heard of it obviously but I'm
out because I'm significantly younger
than you not significant as a big order
I think here well okay
either way easier way Dwight I can't be
there for you I'm sorry Jim I just
really wish there was something I could
do
[Laughter]
that's prank ever
you